Derek Henry the record-tying 99-yard
run that's courtesy the Titans radio
network on the call and from the
one-yard line thus making it 99 Henry
goes down the left sideline and he
trucks AJ boy yay and I still don't know
who number 48 was and I have a feeling
that number of 48 may not be playing for
the jaguars much longer after that
effort although I don't want to take
anything away from Henry Henry was
incredible on that play I didn't know he
could run 99 yards it reminded me the
old bump Phillips line about Earl
Campbell because Earl Campbell couldn't
run a mile he said well I'll never get
to give it to him on first down in a
mile well it was essentially a mile that
Henry migrated down the field last night
to get that 99 yard touchdown Leon
Jacobs was the Jaguars player who had
three or four or five opportunities to
bring down Derek Henry stats as you
pointed out nobody goes low on Derek
Henry probably a good idea to not go low
on Derek Henry I'm just saying me you
guys like six threes a monster you maybe
want to go for his legs 6-3 to 50
yeah but I don't I don't even know that
going low would be a good idea I don't
know how you approach a guy like Derek
Henry when he's running the ball and
he's moving down the field the guy is a
giant and he has been confounding all
year long right
where has this guy been his best game of
the year before last night was 58 yards
his longest run before last night was 16
he had a 99 and a 54-yard touchdown run
last night he had four touchdowns in all
238 rushing yards on 17 carries a
franchise record and that's a franchise
that includes Chris Johnson obviously CJ
2k from 2009 when he had over 2000 yards
and it goes back to Earl Campbell the
aforementioned Campbell who never had a
99 yard run that's for sure Tony Dorsett
the only other guy in league history to
do it Dorsett did it in January of 83 I
remember watching that game on Monday
Night Football against the Vikings the
Cowboys had 10 players on the field but
I would say Henry's run was even more
impressive because Dorsett basically
made one cut and outran everyone there
was a guy for the Vikings that was kind
of making a half-hearted effort to
tackle him Henry had to earn all 99 of
those yards and I still didn't think he
was gonna make it to the end zone it was
incredible
and the Derrick Henry angle took a game
that otherwise would have been so boring
that you would have found something else
to watch and it made it compelling
because we wanted to see how many
touchdowns he was gonna score we wanted
to see how many yards he was going to
gain and there was a moment in the
fourth quarter after he got the
franchise record of 238 Derrick Henry
actually came out of the game with that
football that record-setting football
and the Titans were down in goal line
area and there was a clamoring at Nissan
stadium for Henry to get a shot at
touchdown number five now Henry wanted
to give Dion Lewis a chance to score but
eventually on third and goal Henry went
back on the field it was a run to the
left
the Jaguars bottled him up and they
celebrated like they had just won a
playoff game and that's a bad look for a
team that was that ineffective on
Thursday night after shutting out Andrew
Luck and the Colts on Sunday to get
shredded by Derrick Henry to have no one
on the field that would muster the will
to even challenge Derrick Henry
physically in a meaningful way to
celebrate because you tackled him once
when you're down 32 nine bad look and
then on the next play the Titans threw
it to the end zone and they broke up the
pass at the back corner of the end zone
and they celebrated again it's like
you're losing 32 9 mute it just a little
bit I'm not saying don't show some
satisfaction that you won that play but
don't act like you just won the game
that was that I somebody texted me last
night with another team and said in that
moment you get an idea of a lot of
what's wrong with the jaguars right now
from a cultural standpoint because you
shouldn't be celebrating to that level
when you manage to keep Derrick Henry
out of the end zone for a fifth time
that's nothing hey he only scored four
touchdowns on his last night take that
I'm reluctant to point this out I talked
about it on the radio side because
nobody cares about anyone's fantasy team
but I have a feeling a lot of you out
there went through the same mental
gymnastics that I went through last
night but forgot to actually execute
when the Titans were on their first
drive of the game it dawned on me that I
had not removed Derrick Henry from both
of my fantasy lineups and replaced him
with Spencer where who's now
starting tailback for the Kansas City
Chiefs after what happened with Kareem
hunt and you know Spencer where in that
offense even though it's the Ravens I
was thinking you'll probably have a
better game that Derrick Henry just
because Derrick Henry has been for most
of the year not all that great although
in recent weeks he's been a little bit
better and I have never been so happy to
have forgotten to do something in my
life because I just flat-out forget I
intended to do it and I forgot to do it
and 47.8 points later Derrick Henry had
a huge night and I got the impression a
lot of other people did the same thing
although there were some people who did
remember to bench him how would you feel
today if you had Derrick Henry in your
lineup and you outsmarted yourself by
yanking him for someone else although
there was no read that's what makes it
so amazing like when Tony Dorsett does
it in early 83 he's Tony Dorsett he's in
the midst of a Hall of Fame career
Derrick Henry has largely been a
disappointment during his time in the
NFL and he exploded last night it was
amazing it was incredible and and it's
one of those things we've talked about
this with other players I think stats
when you have a game like that that's
like the kid that constantly brings home
a c-minus report card all of a sudden
getting straight A's you get a pat on
the back from mom and dad and then the
next thing that he said is why aren't
you doing this more often
and that's gonna be the question for
Derrick Henry going forward right what
happened to the guy that we saw in that
Thursday night in December against the
Jaguars
where is he now like all of a sudden the
bar is higher than it was when Henry
became a second round pick and there was
a sense that Henry had maybe slid a
little bit that the Titans had gotten to
steal with Derrick Henry when they
drafted him out of Alabama and you know
that narrative with the Alabama running
backs that they're chewed up and spit
out by Nick Saban and they have nothing
left physically when they get to the NFL
Mark Ingram has done pretty well for
himself coming out of Alabama and
playing for the Saints he's still going
strong but Derrick Henry making his mark
last night and if he can keep playing
like that and that may be a big if and
if the Titans can keep playing like that
and that may be a big if because they've
been Jekyll and Hyde all year long three
games left Giants I can't remember who
they play after that and then the cult's
Giants Washington in the Colts thank you
don't ask the last hour you didn't know
so I didn't even bother
ask you this this time Giants Washington
and the cults if they can play like they
did last night they can maybe steal that
six seed in the AFC now the Ravens are
currently ahead of them but the Ravens
are playing the Chiefs this weekend they
may fall to seven and six Titans at 7
and 6 and who knows how it goes we were
talking just the other day which of the
six and six teams in the AFC and the NFC
have the chance to find the gas pedal
down the stretch and crash the playoff
party and the Titans had the first
chance to do it and they found that gas
pedal Derek Henry found that gas pedal
and no one from that Jacksonville
defense wanted to make a meaningful
effort to tackle him all night long it
was great to see if you're a Titans fan
it was not great to see if you're a
Jaguars fan Jalen Ramsey star
quarterback of the Jaguars and the guy
who had the first crack at Henry on that
long run here's what Ramsey had to say
after the game about the team's
performance Saturday why yeah it looks
like
Henry hadn't done much tougher bottom
tonight and much this year he did a lot
tonight I thought it matter so Jalen
Ramsey accepting reality the Jaguars now
eliminated from playoff consideration
and what happens with Doug Marrone
now the win over the Colts on Sunday may
have helped him I don't know what shot
Conn the owner of that team is going to
do he's been firing the managers of his
soccer club I'm shocked that I even know
that the term is manager of his soccer
club in England fairly regularly in
recent years will there be a change at
the head coaching position will there be
a change at GM will there be a change at
the very top of the football operation
does the Tom Coughlin experiment end
after two years I don't know but they're
they're likely will be more
accountability than simply Nathaniel
Hackett being fired as offensive
coordinator and Blake bortles being
benched it looks like they didn't even
consider putting bortles in the game
last night when the game was out of
reach I think they want to see what they
have in Cody Kessler because I think
they need to make a decision after the
year what they're going to do at
quarterback and if you're a jaguars fan
and they expect you to show up and buy
tickets you'd like to think they're
gonna give you something better than
Cody Kessler for 2019 all due respect to
Cody Kessler stats you've suggested that
they should load up the cannon and trade
for somebody like a Matthew Stafford I
first of all I don't see the Lions
trading I think the Lions are gonna ride
with him for one more year I just don't
think they need to be that desperate and
I don't know that Matthew Stafford is
the answer I don't know that you want to
go all the way to the other end of the
spectrum although right now Stafford is
in the middle of the pack it's gonna be
expensive to get him it's gonna be
expensive to keep him I think there may
be some options out there there's gonna
be some guys who become available in
free agency Teddy Bridgewater he's gonna
be available maybe they just you know
will they will they admit that they
screwed up last year they've already
kind of admitted it by benching Blake
bortles
they could have had Teddy Bridgewater
after the 2017 season as a free agent do
they go after him now I think he'd be
perfect you know there was talk of Eli
Manning a year ago I think he's playing
his way into another season with the
Giants I don't know the Giants are gonna
want to trade him but you know and also
here's the other thing with the Jaguars
after last
year they had that vibe of a team that
maybe should just go all in try to get
to the next level do it for one year for
a short-term veteran quarterback now I
feel like it's gonna be a lot murkier
because I don't know that next year you
can say hey the Jaguars are just one
quarterback away from making a Superbowl
run and even if it's only a guy who's
gonna be there a year or two let's do it
you know like the Vikings when they went
after Brett Favre in 2009 all of a
sudden the Jaguars have lost that it
feels like they have a lot more work to
do on that team to get back to the point
where there's simply a competent
quarterback away from being a a great
team but you know things can change
dramatically for good and for bad
we've seen it change dramatically for
bad for the jaguars in one year they
could be right back in the thick of
things next year but obviously they're
going to have to have a better
quarterback play if they want to be
relevant again and meanwhile the Titans
are trending upward the cults are
trending upward the Texans are trending
upward this is becoming one of the best
divisions in the NFL wasn't that long
ago that the AFC South was just that
division like well well one of them's
got to win it
one of them's getting a playoff game and
probably going one and out in the
playoffs now they've got viable playoff
contenders top to bottom when when the
last-place team was a Final Four team a
year ago that's a pretty good division
so next year who knows what that means
to the Jacksonville Jaguars and the rest
of the AFC
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports